du geschockten Gesichtern im Pongoland
dem Affenhaus des Leipziger Zoos hier
erschüttert nämlich gerade eine grausame
Tat die Mitarbeiter und vor allem auch
die Besucher während der regulären
Öffnungszeiten treiben die Schimpansen
ihren ehemaligen Anführer Robert in den
Tod
Robert der einstige Chef der Affen des
Leipziger Zoos Tod ertrunken in einem
Wassergraben eine aufgebrachte Meute
junge Schimpansen sie hetzen Robert
unerbittlich gnadenlos quer durch das
Pongoland in Leipziger Zoo der einst
stolze Anführer der Affenbande hat keine
Chance brutal von seinen Artgenossen in
die Enge getrieben springt er in den
nassen Tod ein verzweifelter ein
tragischer Sprung denn die Schimpansen
des Leipziger Zoos können nicht
schwimmen meiden das Wasser um jeden
Preis Rückblick jahrelang ist Robert das
Alphatier der Chef im Affenhaus hält die
Gruppe zusammen beendet Rangeleien und
setzt sich mühelos gegen die jungen
Wilden durch die ihn stürzen wollen doch
mit den Jahren wird Robert schwächer mit
47 schon längst im Affen Ruhestand das
Zepter der Macht hat er bereits vor
Jahren an seinen Sohn den 29 Jahre alten
Frodo übergeben geht ihm seither aber
lieber aus dem Weg bis jetzt hat Frodo
womöglich seinen eigenen Vater auf dem
Gewissen der Schock sitzt tief im
Leipziger Zoo traut man um einen der
treuesten Bewohner einen echten
Charakter um Robert
[Musik]